(Niko) Hi everyone, we have some exciting news. (Sam) Over the last 12 months, it's gotten incredibly busy here. We are shooting,
we are editing we're doing tons of stuff. (Niko) We're making more videos than we ever have before,
and we are running into bottlenecks and we need your help.
(Sam) So if you are a professional editor... (Niko) And you want to work in this crazy environment that we call Corridor Digital... Trust me,
it's actually not that crazy. When the camera's not rolling, we're all just grinding away. (Jake) Cut- You'll cut that part. (Sam) With editing!
(Jake) Yeah! (Sam) Then we would like for you to apply to work here at Corridor Digital. "How do I apply?" you may ask.
Well, it's really simple. Basically, in the description,
We have included a link to a bunch of clips from an unreleased video and we want you to edit them with your
style. Once you've done that, send us a link to that video, following our very strict formatting instructions.
(Jake) Format it this way: in the subject line, put "Corridor Job Application"
followed by vertical line followed by your name, and then in the body of the e-mail, put your name again with an unlisted YouTube link,
and that's it. (Sam) When all the emails will look the same,
all we're gonna do is just judge you by how good your video is. (Jake) Please format and send this email correctly.
We're gonna get hundreds and hundreds of these emails. If you guys don't format the e-mail correctly, it's real simple...
I'm probably not gonna watch the video because you didn't format the e-mail correctly, and... (Sam) One small note!
You might not be aware of this but our studio is currently located in Los Angeles, California.
(Niko) Oh, that's an important one. (Sam) So, if you do happen to be selected as an applicant,
you might have to move here. (Jake) Applications will end at the end of day on March 15th, Pacific Time.
I'll be looking for all of your beautifully formatted e-mails with your incredible edits.
We will announce when we have found somebody.
Follow us on Twitter or Instagram, or obviously on the channels, and we'll do updates as we- as we move through the process.
(Niko) Thank you for listening to our video, and if you are considering applying, thank you for putting in the time for the application.
I know editing can be a lot of work. We are flattered with every single application that comes in.
It means a lot to us, honestly.
And that's when you cut away from me.
(Sam) Editing... Editing... (Jake) So... (Niko) See, what's the problem right now is, this video is not being edited.
(Jake) Someone please edit this!
(Niko) Where's my editor?
(Sam) Help! It's not cutting (Jake) It's not cutting! (Sam) Yeah, cut the clip! Cut the dang clip! (Jake) Something cut!
(Niko) They'll just- just do a record on a VHS tape, and it's us literally-
[test tone]